these are the stars of monkey d luffy
the hero of one piece the trademark one
he has under his left eye that he
inflicted on himself to prove his
determination to become a pirate to
shanks and of course the large gruesome
looking one on his chest in the shape of
a giant x where a kainoos attack hit him
after he had taken ace's life both of
them are reminders of the two most
life-altering moments in luffy's life a
visual representation if you like of
luffy's determination to become a great
pirate and of the tragic loss of his
older brother and his failure at
marinefords and when i thought about it
for a second it hit me it's not only
luffy scars that represent who he is as
a person and what path he follows no
this is true for every single character
in the story that carries some sort of
scar zorro kaido shanks nami
whitebeard every single scar they carry
is a manifestation of what they have
gone through and what they stand for but
it gets even crazier than that because i
think i've discovered that these scars
reveal to us many of the things that
still have to happen before the end of
the story in my opinion making it one of
the most badass ways of storytelling in
the entire story to me and for me luffy
is of course the best person to begin
with because well he's the protagonist
so what do the marks on his rubbery body
tell us about the end of one piece well
as i've said these scars represent the
most important events in luffy's entire
life both of which are still unresolved
the knife cut under his left eye is a
constant reminder throughout the story
that our rubbery boy had one dream and
one dream only his entire life not
becoming a doctor and then a marine and
then a pirate no
luffy wanted to become the pirate king
ever since he met shanks to me it almost
feels like a physical representation of
his oath that he will become a great
pirate and it's also a reminder of
shank's sacrifice the lesson he taught
luffy and the pup with the mountain
bandits and of course the moment that
luffy consumed his devil fruit that
actually was the thing that set him on
his path to become a pirate captain and
start his own crew it also proves to us
and i guess to luffy himself as well
right from the start that he's aware
that the path to freedom will be painful
and full of sacrifices but that he's
still willing to take all of it on and
so i think it's pretty fair to say that
this little scar is a summary of luffy's
origins and his motivation for what he's
doing and trying to achieve throughout
the entire story but what exactly does
this tell us about the ending well as
you've probably guessed this scar also
commemorates his promise to shanks to
return the legendary straw hat that was
passed down from roger to him to luffy
symbolizing shanks's trust in luffy as
the one who can bring the dawn and
change the worlds while the scar keeps
reminding us that luffy is still trying
to become that great pirate it also
promises us a reunion of these two men
that will mark luffy as ready to claim
the throne of the pirate worlds which as
you know i believe should be happening
pretty soon now and so i see this car
basically as a sort of guarantee that we
will have a reunion between shanks and
luffy and of course of luffy becoming
pirate king so that the promise that is
sealed in his cheek now can be fulfilled
shanks by the way who of course carries
two major scars as well his lost arm
though i guess that's a pretty damn big
scar that is basically shanks's
counterpart to luffy's reminding us of
him and their promise meanwhile the
three distinct claw marks over his eyes
that he received during a confrontation
with blackbeard represent his future
quest to stop teach from gaining power
something that he has failed to do so
far this scar also is a promise to us
that the relationship between shanks and
blackbeard will have some sort of payoff
later in the story it could of course be
an actual meeting between these two with
a chance for shanks to fulfill his
mission though we both know that that
probably would have no good ending for
him
or alternatively we will at least get
the story behind shanks's chase of teach
and the secrets that both of them
clearly know about the worlds that we're
still unaware of and so i like to see
this triple scar as a representation of
shanks's all-seeing nature and of his
attempt to stop blackbeard i mean he
even presents it to whitebeard during
their meeting who by the way mentions
his own scars he received from roger
when he sees shanks as well in case
you're wondering why that is it's of
course because shanks was part of
roger's crew so seeing shanks reminds
whitebeard of his old rival and all the
fights and feasts that they've
experienced together really his major
life events and battles commemorated on
his chest they also really nicely
represent whitebeard's character someone
who always stood protectingly in front
of his crew which he called his family
something that he ordered the author of
one piece actually dedicated an entire
page to at his passing showing a very
emotional me at that time that this man
didn't have a single scar on his back
never running away and always facing his
enemies head on without any doubt one of
my all-time favorite moments in the
entire story and it's made extra
powerful because oda sensei doesn't tell
us all this but simply shows us his
scars and the lack thereof on his back
brilliance and of course whitebeard's
death at marineford how he came prepared
to die so that his son ace could live
and how a kind who put a very
unfortunate end to his dreams and era
all of it is deeply engraved in luffy's
chest in the shape of his gaping
x-shaped scar in case you forgot he
received it when his own brother gave
his life to protect his and when jimbei
also risked being killed to protect
luffy as i've discussed in a lot of
detail before in a number of character
analysis i did on luffy marineford and
ace's death were the lowest point in his
arc and the moment that he grew the most
as a character the need to take the
world more seriously to learn that
failure is a real possibility and to get
strong enough to protect his crew and
change the world basically it's another
promise that luffy makes to himself when
he starts his training with rayleigh
that is enclosed in his healing wound in
his chest the x by the way i really like
to think is a nice nod to the x that ace
had in his tattoo in memory of their
third brother sabo's jolly roger and
maybe even more interestingly the scar
also tells us more about luffy and his
ability to make people love and trust
him because it is the product of his
brother and jinbe and the entire
whitebeard pirates as a whole basically
protecting him and once again i think it
does tell us things that will definitely
have to happen in the story there's of
course luffy's eventual encounter with
akainu and how luffy will deal with the
man that killed his brother will he
fight him will he forgive him i really
can't wait to find out and i personally
also like to think that the scar sets up
the possible death of another person
that's close to luffy only that this
time luffy will be able to stop it
whether this will be sabo or one of the
straw hats or someone completely else i
don't know but i feel that this scar
will serve as a reminder to luffy that
he became stronger to not lose another
person like he did with ace i mean if
you wanted to be really poetic about
this you could probably even say that
these scars represent the inherited will
of the people they're connected to
shanks and ace that luffy now carries
and here i thought that scars couldn't
get any cooler but they clearly did okay
but here's the real reason why i think
that these scars let us know exactly
what still needs to happen in the story
because what i've noticed is that
certain fights leave characters like
luffy or zorro with lasting scars well
others don't biggest example here luffy
doesn't have a scar from the fight with
katakuri despite probably being the most
vile wound he received yet or being
impaled by crocodile i mean in theory if
luffy's little knife left a scar
shouldn't he be covered in scars from
all of his fights and so i honestly
think that the reason that only certain
wounds leave scars is because they
represent an unresolved or ongoing
conflict of the character luffy needs to
meet shanks and face a kainu shanks and
blackbeard zaro and mihawk though i do
want to save zorro scars for a whole
separate video if you want to see that
then you of course have the scars of
both akainu and aokiji reminding them of
their unresolved conflict of how the
marines should be led but maybe my
favorite example of all is the scar that
odin gave to kaido the giant cut across
his chest because even though odin is
dead kaido's conflict about that fight
is far from over the fact that he won
this duel in an inhonorable way because
someone distracted odin still haunts him
to this day i go into much more detail
about this all in kaido's character
analysis but to sum it up for here this
scar embodies the burden that kaido has
put on himself to reach his goal to
change the world even if it means going
against his honor that is so important
to him and the joy of fighting against a
strong opponent in a fair fight and so
the scar is there because kaido is still
struggling with what it really
represents
scar across her shoulder embodies her
struggle under arlon and how she
ultimately got saved by luffy and so the
only reason you don't see her scar is
because she decided to put a tattoo over
it making it vanish because the conflict
connected to it has been resolved or
take brille and her scar across her face
that represented her ongoing conflict
with her own family and also category
struggle to be the strong older brother
that can't show any kind of weakness as
you might remember brulee got the scar
after being attacked by other kids until
katakuri stepped in to protect her
katakuri by the way with his own scars
around his mouth that he got from eating
too many donuts pretty cool by the way
that he got bullied for in the end and
thus made him forever hide his face
until luffy came around for him and so
spinning this a bit further i think the
reason why luffy doesn't carry a scar
from this fight with katakuri is because
there is no more conflict between them
they're basically two men who helped
each other and found deep respect for
their opponents now katakuri on the
other hand i wouldn't be at all
surprised if he had kept a scar of where
he stabbed himself after all it's a
really cool reminder of how luffy
changed his life physical proof for his
honor as a man for making the fight fair
and opening up the chance to reunite
with luffy in the future as a possible
ally another fantastic example for this
would be kit and his new scar that he
got from shanks it also embodies the
unresolved conflict between these two
and how kid wants to take down the yonko
above all else and if you want to know
the whole story behind kit and all the
rage and anger that he has and why he
thinks he needs to take down all the
yonko on his own well then you just
really can't miss out on this video
right here where i explain all that and
much much more